-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
I appreciate this.
I'm very excited about this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The star
of "John Wick: Chapter 4,"
Keanu Reeves,
is my guest tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I knew Keanu was here
when I saw 20 security guards
knocked out in the hallway.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, it is that time
of year again.
March Madness
has officially begun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's nothing more fun
than carefully filling out
your bracket
and then losing to a coworker
who pronounces UCLA
as "uch-lah."
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations.
Games are being played on CBS,
TBS, TNT, and TruTV.
Unfortunately, by the time
you find TruTV,
all the games are over,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
Why are they still
calling it that?
Just call it the
"Impractical Jokers" Network.
Yeah, I know that.
-Come on.
-I know that channel.
TruTV.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But I heard that this year,
Americans will bet more than
$15 billion on March Madness.
[ Crowd exclaims ]
People are like,
"Hey, at this point,
it's safer than putting money
in the banks."
[ Laughter ]
-Ka-ching!
-I could win something
on this one.
The first big upset
was the second game
of the tournament
when 13-seed Furman University
beat 4-seed Virginia.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was a really exciting game,
and I noticed that
Furman's cheerleaders
had a pretty interesting chant.
Watch this.
-FU!
[ Laughter ]
-FU.
-Yeah.
-Furman University, yeah, yeah.
-I want to say it's innocent,
but they only chant that
when the other team scores.
That's very interesting.
Just saying.
Well, people are talking
about this.
The Biden Administration
is ordering
the Chinese parent company
of TikTok
to either sell the app
or face a possible ban.
[ Crowd oohs ]
It is a bold move by Biden.
If he bans TikTok, China will
only be able to spy on us
with literally everything else.
[ Laughter ]
Man, if Biden actually does
ban TikTok,
I'm pretty sure half the country
will be like --
-FU!
-Yeah, yeah.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Furman University.
-Yeah. Furman.
-I love them. That's great.
Guys, I read that Chris Christie
said in the next 45 to 60 days,
he will announce whether or not
he's running for president.
[ Crowd exclaims ]
-Oh.
-When asked about making
a decision,
Christie said, "Well,
we'll cross that bridge
when we close it --
I mean, when we get to it.
When we get to it, not --
I didn't say close.
They closed it?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Some business news --
Kellogg's announced
that they're splitting
into two separate companies,
one for cereal
and one for snacks.
Right now, they're trying
to figure out who gets custody
of Snap, Crackle, and Pop,
but we'll figure that out.
Yep, cereal and snacks
are splitting up,
but sadly, neither side
wants Cracklin' Oat Bran.
[ Laughter ]
"I don't want to go
near that stuff."
New snack company will be called
Kellanova.
I actually have $100 on
Kellanova to win March Madness.
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this, guys.
Spring break is in full swing
down in Miami Beach,
and following noise complaints
from residents,
a judge ruled that the city
can order bars
to change their last call
from 5:00 a.m. to 2:00 a.m.
-Ohhh.
-Yep.
[ Crowd boos ]
Miami residents were mad.
They were like, "You know,
when we bought this condo
next to a Señor Frog's, we had
no idea it would be like this.
[ Laughter ]
No idea
that it would get rowdy!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Señor Frog's!
And finally, New York City just
introduced brand-new subway cars
with eight security cameras
in each car.
And they're stolen.
[ Laughter ]
The city politely asked
that if you do commit a crime,
do it on one of those
five cars.